[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACK WEIXEL: My
name is Jack Weixel.
And I manage global partnerships
for something in Android
that we call dedicated devices.
I'll explain a little bit
more about what that is.
But for now, you
can think about that
as anything that's not
a smartphone, right?
So all the other use cases
that we'll talk about
falls into that category.
I want to have a discussion
today about a couple of things.
One-- I want to talk
about in Android,
why we're placing a focus
on the enterprise use cases,
how we're addressing
those use cases,
what some of the
trends in industry
that we've seen regarding
the use of mobile operating
systems, and give
you some examples.
And I'll show
customer use cases.
That's my favorite part.
And what I hope to do is walk
through, give some examples.
We'll open up the
floor to questions
afterwards in case you have
some observations, questions,
and obviously happy to
talk more about that.
So I'm going to start out
with a couple of numbers.
There's no Google
presentation that
can be done without numbers
to start things off with.
And some of those numbers
you may already know.
For example, there's 2.3
billion monthly active users
on Android--
every month 2.3
billion devices that
are used that are GMS devices.
That's Google Mobile Services.
You can think of that as
Play Services, everything
we use too in a mobile phone.
I'm going to talk a
little bit more in detail
why this is important.
But I wanted to talk first
off about what that scale is.
Just to give you an indication,
no other operating system
has ever shipped 2.3
billion copies, right?
And that's what we have--
monthly active users.
That has a lot of
implications, so
what we have to do
for the ecosystem
and how we need to build it.
That also has implications about
what we're doing in enterprise.
A key to that is Google Play.
Obviously smartphones or
enterprise use cases--
enterprise devices require the
ability to install, manage, .
Update various applications on
a device and it is just massive.
There's about 8r-- sorry,
94 billion apps were down--
94 billion apps were
downloaded last year.
We see about 8 billion
installs every month.
So if you think
about that-- in order
to manage that and ensure
security and ensure usability,
ensure consistency, we've
had to take all that
into consideration
as we're building out
to support this ecosystem.
And we're creating that
ability to address this
that you could take
advantage of an enterprise--
even with your
enterprise use cases.
Now one set of numbers
you may not be aware of
is the fact that there will
be about 300 million Android
phones that were shipped
for business use this year.
That's just for business use.
And we've broken
down because of how
we address the market into those
that are personally liable--
bring your own device--
or something that's
corporate owned--
227 million in personal liable
and 60 million in corporate
owned.
Now 78% of devices--
78% of all the devices
shipped for business
are Android devices.
So that's a big why as
to why we're building out
what used to be considered kind
of a consumer operating system.
And quite frankly, we went
to market initially focused
on consumers until we
saw a huge increase
in the business market.
And since Lollipop,
we've spent an awful lot
of time building in capabilities
to address enterprise use
cases.
Now the reason that
that's important
is prior to this
point, there were
lots of entrepreneurs creating
ways to manage, deploy, utilize
these devices.
And they all ended
up being proprietary.
And all ended up
fragmenting the marketplace.
We recognized that there was
contrary to everything else we
did at Android, number one.
It mentioned the bit about
compatibility and ensuring
usability and so forth.
If you have
fragmentation like this,
that hurts everybody
across the ecosystem.
So we decided to do,
starting in Lollipop,
is really deliver
in the platform
the ability to manage devices
in a consistent fashion.
We can take a look and see
Work Profile and Fully Managed.
That's a scenario,
where, Fully Managed--
obviously the corporation
owns the device.
You know, Work Profile
is where a corporation
owns a folder on your device.
It's a separate user--
complete data separation
for those use cases.
That's all I'm going to
say about Work Profile,
because that's not
what this is about.
But those are the two key pieces
to the management capability.
When we got to
Marshmallow, that's
when we started
really focusing more
on the enterprise
use cases that were
different from a smartphone.
So we introduced Lock
Task mode, the ability
to set devices up more
easily in Kiosk mode.
So you can deploy business
use cases-- something that
might be unattended,
something that
will be different than
a smartphone scenario.
And we've continued all through
these next couple of releases
more and more capabilities that
were addressed-- that simply
address the enterprise
use cases, including
being able to allow multiple
shifts for being able to log
into a device more easily.
Instead of having to manage
all of that software in a very
awkward fashion, we allow you
to sign in and sign out with P
with these various devices.
That will apply to some
of the [? use case ?]
I'll talk about in
Rugged, as well as
any of the public facing
multi-user sessions that we
talk about.
The reason I'm
pointing all of this
out is if you're looking
at enterprise use case
and you're trying to figure
out how to [? put in ?] all
the applications
that you want, you
don't have to build
that capability.
We've got it addressed
in the platform.
You can focus on what's
the value add instead
of just the base capability.
Now underlying all of this-- you
know, the elephant in the room,
by the way, with a
lot of discussions
I had early on when I
joined the Android team
was security and this perception
that Android was less secure
than other operating systems.
That's sort of been job
number one at Android--
making sure that we address
that through security updates,
other capabilities
that we do that we'll
touch on in just a second.
But the pace of security
innovation has been massive--
in fact, so much so that Gartner
tells us that as of Oreo,
we actually surpassed
what they were
seeing in iOS,
which was typically
considered a more secure
operating system than Android.
So the pace has been huge.
It's not that others haven't
been innovating as well.
We've just focused
so much on this.
It's just insane.
So if you're looking at
an enterprise devices,
there's no scenario
where security is more
important than in this piece.
And that's been a
huge focus of ours.
And why does this matter?
The reason all this matters
obviously is that a couple
of the statistics that we've
seen that have been presented
us from various analysts-- so
the fact that 78% of business
leaders-- just a
couple of numbers--
this is Google.
So I've got to give
you some numbers.
78% of business leaders
expect their operations
to be a digital business
in the next few years.
If you take a look
at the chart--
you already know this--
but if you take a look
at the chart in terms of the
growth of these mobile devices,
it's insane in terms of
how quickly that's growing.
The one that I always like to
point to is 90% of IT decision
makers see Enterprise Mobility
as a critical function
for customer engagement,
experience, and so forth.
I think the more
important factor that's
been [? in line, ?] this
is probably 10% of them
have to consider maybe
in a year or so what
they're going to do
at their next job,
you know, quite frankly.
It's gotten to the
point where you
need to be focused on
this type of thing.
Or you need be focused
on something else--
[LAUGHS]
--that may be future employment.
Innovators across the
industry we're seeing
are turning to Android.
Some of the things we'll
talk about, by the way,
are point of sale
and kiosk capability.
And these are-- and
again, I know you all have
copies of this presentation.
You will receive
copies of presentation.
So you can look up some of these
charts that I'll display here.
But the growth in Kiosk--
if you've walked into an airport
lately, right, or fast food
store or just about
anywhere, you've
actually seen in terms
of growth, you know,
what's been happening
in this marketplace.
The point of sale
scenario is going
to be a huge trend-- is going
to undergo a huge transformation
over the next couple of years.
It's already happening with
various restaurants you've
probably walked into--
various hospitals--
you know, hotels,
resorts, and so forth.
We're seeing increase in move
to Android through all of that.
So we need to be able to
support that and reduce
the fragmentation that have been
talked about earlier with some
of the knowledge worker
scenarios in this area
before it actually happens.
So just to give you an
idea, on the far left
are the two scenarios that
we started this whole journey
with.
That's the knowledge worker
devices-- we refer to them--
handsets and tablets--
just accessing email,
corporate data, and so forth.
What we're increasingly
focusing on-- my main objective
is all of these other
types of devices.
And we started with the rugged
devices for a simple reason.
They most approached or looked
like your handsets, right?
If you're familiar
with the Zebras,
the Honeywells, and so
forth, a lot of those devices
look like your handset.
They're ruggedized.
They have other
capabilities and accessories
that people use
to do their jobs.
But they look like a smartphone.
And we used close cooperation
with these vendors
to be able to build into
the platform the way
to address other things,
such as, for example,
on a scanner in
the rugged device
if you're a point
of sale system,
there are other peripherals
you have to connect to.
And the ability to manage
all of this-- again,
going back to the fact that
as you look at these use cases
you want focus on software and
the value add and deliverable,
we need to be able
to address everything
else underneath, from security
to management and so forth.
So what we really want to
do at the end of the day
is allow our partners to
deliver to their customers
devices for any user no
matter what they're doing.
And some of the particular
verticals or areas
that we see huge growth
in-- for example,
in retail, as well
as hospitality.
You know, we'll go into a
couple of retail use cases
in a little bit.
But you're here at Google Cloud.
And when you think
of a customer journey
or if you think of your
operation of your store,
from the time something hits
your dock in the warehouse
[? or ?] the way it
travels through inventory
is delivered to user at the end
of the day, gets replenished.
These are all ripe opportunities
for a Cloud Mobile scenario
to be able to improve processes,
insight into what's happening,
and customer experience
at the end of the day.
Hospitality we'll talk a bit
a little about in more detail
as we get a little further.
But the idea of being
able to interact
with your guests, your
customers in better ways
throughout whatever
the property might be
can be a huge competitive
advantage for you.
And we're working
right now on how
to even go beyond what we've
done in the GMS scenario
to be able to improve
this to a great extent.
Now it's not like
people aren't building.
And some of you in
the room may already
be building some
applications or capabilities
to address these use cases.
But what this started at was
in what we refer to as AOSP.
That's the Android Open
System-- yeah, yeah, yeah--
Open Software Platform.
It's-- sorry--
Android Open Source Platform.
The difference when I refer
to GMS versus AOSP-- anybody
can do anything
they want with AOSP.
You can build something.
Of course, you have to.
We deliver a lot of
things in the platform.
But you have to build your
own ways to manage the device,
deliver applications,
so on, and so forth.
What we wanted to do with GMS--
with Play Service,
the objective is not
to get you to take
devices that have
Search on it, right, or Gmail.
I mean, you could.
There could be use
cases for something
like that-- certainly
Maps and some areas
that we'll talk about.
But really it's Play Services.
When we go back to that
slide I talked about with all
those applications that
get downloaded and think
of having to update
those and address those--
if we leverage that to be able
to deploy these applications
and update applications
to your devices, that
makes your life a lot
easier, as well as being
able to utilize all the
APIs to secure and manage
those devices, as well--
everything we've built into
what we call GMS Core--
and that's the Play
Services underneath
to be able to support this.
And some key pieces
within that story
are the ability to
enhance the security,
be able to deploy in a
very quick and easy way,
and utilize something
we call Manage Play.
So enhanced security--
just to give you
an idea, when we talk about
these types of GMS devices,
all devices that have
Play Services on them
go through an approval process.
So we understand
what the fingerprint
is, what the image looks like.
And we can devise tests that
are done at machine speed,
constantly changing so
that we can tell even--
not just the fact that we
do all the scanning of apps
and make sure that
there isn't potentially
harmful applications being
delivered to your device--
we can tell afterwards
when a device is deployed,
whether it's been routed,
whether it's been tampered
with, whether it's still
secure, whether there
are problems with it.
We can continue to
secure those devices even
after if the application's
been deployed,
the device is
deployed, and so forth.
Zero Touch Bulk Enrollment
is the capability
to, in a summary fashion,
be able to take a device out
of the box, turn it on, sign in.
And everything
happens automatically.
Your EMM gets attached to it.
Your applications
get downloaded.
It gets booted in the fashion
that you expect it to be done--
all of that without
user interaction.
We make it very easy to
be able to deploy this.
So again, when you're talking,
in an enterprise sense,
of the scale of thousands of
devices in multiple locations,
the ability to take advantage
of this and deploy apps
is critical.
Manage Google Play-- again, I
want to come back to the point
that when I talk about
Google Play a lot of times,
people think of
consumer apps, right?
You're going to download
Candy Crush or whatever--
[LAUGHS]
--onto a device.
Manage Google Play
means the admin,
the company gets to
decide exactly what's
available on the device,
exactly what the application
store looks like,
as a matter of fact.
You can open up to the world.
You can publish
only private apps.
You can publish private
apps only to your devices.
You can allow a mix--
whatever you decide to do.
And by the way, you can
make invisible to the user
and just deliver these
to the devices in a time
fashion that you choose and with
complete control over what's
happening.
So all of this is an enterprise
focus, utilizing that platform,
but doing it in such a way
that you have complete control.
This is not, you know, an open
to Google, open to the world
type of scenario.
And by the way, one of the
things I always get asked about
is what is Google
looking at on my devices.
A key thing with Manage Google
Play is it's a device account.
It's not a user account.
So we alleviate the concern
over people wondering
what's made available,
what's viewed, what's seen,
and so forth.
Now because of all
this work that we've
done, when we take a look
at the percentage of devices
that are free of
potentially harmful apps--
99.99% of devices.
And the two bars we have here--
the green one is one that is
not using Google Play only
to deploy apps.
You know, the blue one
is using Google Play only
to go ahead and do that.
The alternative, by the way, to
do this is to side load an app.
To side load an app, you
have to open up your device
to install applications
from unknown sources
and utilize something called
a device administrator or EPI,
which we're
deprecating, by the way.
This opens up security--
[LAUGHS]
--holes that did not
exist in Android.
And going back to what I
talked about earlier, that
was a key reason we
had to close that off
and deliver an alternative
so that you can actually
have this kind of result.
And I'll tell you what--
the green-- every-- because
of all the capabilities
that we built into Android
to improve security,
you see even the green
going down dramatically.
But its worst point--
5.3% of devices.
Yeah, I imagine
[? all ?] your desktops,
you'd be pretty happy
with potentially only 5.3%
of those devices.
But we're not happy with that.
We want 0.01%.
And that's what we get
at the end of the day
with taking advantage of
this kind of platform.
So it's not just making it easy.
It's not making it consistent.
It's actually making
it rock solid secure.
And I've talked about rugged.
That was the first group
to actually engage with us
from the enterprise scenario.
We've seen a huge trend.
These are reported to us by
partners and analysts in terms
of where the market is going.
And you think about it.
These types of devices-- this
comes from an industry, where
people want to lock things off
from exposure to the internet,
because they want to
secure the device, right?
So in this marketplace
when people
are accepting Android
and moving to Android,
we're winning the game, because
we're delivering results
that we expect to do.
So let me talk about
a couple of things.
I want to start--
by the way, there's
a couple of videos.
There's only a couple
that I'll actually play.
But these videos-- you can go to
Android.com/Enterprise and take
a look and see what they
actually use cases are.
And I encourage you to
do so, because they're
pretty interesting--
the innovation
and what people are
doing in these scenarios.
But an example of what we're
talking about here-- and this
is Walmart.
And they're using Zebra devices.
And I believe SAP is
their Cloud application
that they're delivering.
They've-- obviously you're
familiar with Walmart.
Think about two
million employees.
And what they are faced with
a scenario where they wanted
to be able to give one
device to their associates
to do a number of
different things.
And they will look up prices.
They will actually
scan and take a look
at inventory, what's available.
And in the same app--
in the same device,
they'll be able to say, OK.
Well, I'm out of this product.
When's my delivery date, right?
They can see that
on their device.
They can take a look and
see when they have ordered.
They can start to make decisions
based on what trends have been,
you know, not just a device, but
from the corporate standpoint
by connecting this to
obviously a Cloud App to be
able to make better decisions
about when they're going
to order, what they're going to
do improving customer journeys,
and so forth.
This is the type of
back to front scenario
that we've seen repeatedly
in this industry.
And this is a really
good example of it.
What I love about
this, though, is
that I've seen this come up in
a number of different use cases,
where someone
unsolicited will say,
you know, it works just
like my smartphone.
And if you think
about it, when you're
talking about doing a
transformational change--
transforming any
business process,
getting somebody to do something
a little bit different,
introducing a new product,
the most difficult thing
is getting somebody
to accept it and be
able to learn what
to do differently
than they had been before.
Taking advantage of a platform
where you get that reaction--
it's just like my
smartphone-- that makes
your job a whole lot easier.
And that's one of
the reasons people
will turn to Android to
go ahead and do this.
So from this perspective, it's
a great use case to take a look
and see how people are
using these devices to be
able to get a 360 degree
view of everything that's
happening in the enterprise.
So what we've done to be able to
support all of these activities
is to be able to introduce
a couple of key programs
into the scenario.
One is what we call Android
Enterprise Recommended.
We were constantly
asked, what do you
recommend for an enterprise to
use-- what types of devices.
And this applies,
as we eventually
realized, not just to a
particular phone that you're
going to use for email,
but across the board
to rugged devices, to EMMs--
everything that's
part of the ecosystem.
And we built an Android
Enterprise Recommended program
to even ensure that you're
going to have conference
as a customer in
selecting a device,
consistency in deployment, and
making sure that it's current
and up to date.
We have requirements in terms
of how quickly app devices need
to be upgraded--
security updates delivered,
and so forth, so as well
as making sure that it can
be delivered and deployed
with zero touch in all the
ways that we expect to do.
It's going to look and feel the
same way when it's deployed.
Obviously all these capabilities
are important from an Android
Enterprise Recommended.
But again, coming
back to anything
that you might be doing in
your particular business,
you can be comfortable
in the fact
that we've built
the infrastructure
and the capability,
particularly if you
choose some of these partners,
to be able to deploy things
in a way that makes
a lot of sense
and you can be very
comfortable with.
So just to get a quick view
from the rugged perspective,
by the way, we started
out with five OEMs.
That quickly expanded.
There's still a few more--
[LAUGHS]
--that are waiting
to be updated.
So it's been a huge uptake.
And one of the
simple reasons are
is people are starting
now to make choices
on particular devices based
on whether they're Android
Enterprise Recommended or not.
Customers always want to
be comfortable with what
they're buying.
OK.
So that's a little bit of the
background on what we're doing
and why we're doing it.
But let's talk about some
of these Android Dedicated
Devices.
And the rugged device
we already talked about.
But what we're doing
is now seeing--
is we've talked about more
activity in point of sale,
embedded devices,
kiosk scenarios.
And when you think about
this and all the capabilities
that Google will bring,
not just in terms
of device in your
scenario, one thing
that I didn't mention
a couple of slides back
that I'll bring
I'll bring up now
as we talk about this, because
when you take a look at this,
when kiosk and point of sale,
retail is a great vertical.
And when you think back
to you what you do,
particularly if you're
in a retail segment
in all aspects of
your business, one
of the things I mentioned
a few slides back
is other Google technologies.
You know, one key is
augmented reality.
So imagine, if you
will, a scenario
where you could take a device--
and you are in a warehouse-- to
be able to walk through and use
augmented reality for anyone
that wants to pick something
to be able to go
immediately to that shelf
or to be able to
walk to a scenario
where you're fixing a component
and to be able to have overlaid
not only instructions on what
to fix-- maybe it's actually
because you've already captured
information about which device
is failing, you know, what
needs to be done, and so forth.
The device can actually
lead you to understand
what you need to do and which
device needs to be replaced,
all of which, by the
way, exists right now.
And those are use cases
people are delivering.
So you can build that type of
capability into your scenario.
So how are some of the
dedicated devices being used?
And in full disclosure,
this particular slide
is actually an example.
But I stole it from
the Chrome guys,
because this was actually
a Chrome deployment.
You can do the same
thing in Android.
What you may not be aware
of is there are proximity
APIs in all these devices.
So if you have an application--
maybe you're a retailer.
And you have an application--
might be a loyalty app.
And someone has
actually opted in
to be able to get offers
or notices from you.
As they walk by a
particular display that
could be geared to be
able to deliver to them
either content offers
and so forth that
would apply to that individual.
So these are the types
of things that actually,
if it's done in
the right way, can
be really compelling
in a user experience.
So Chronopost is
a delivery company
based in Paris similar to
FedEx, UPS, and so forth.
And a while back,
they decided that they
needed to revamp their fleet.
They're delivering about
a million packages a day.
And they saw a lot
of inefficiencies
throughout the whole
scenario, from being
able to track what devices
are picked up to be scheduling
routes and so forth.
What they opted to do is they
worked with a partner, Zebra,
and one of our EMM partners
to be able to design a system,
whereby they would be
able to have a driver--
number one, when he
walks in in the morning
to be able to pick a
device up and drop it
into his truck or her truck.
And it's got the map laid out.
It's got all his
delivery schedule already
set up for him.
He just has to follow, you
know, what the device is
telling him to do.
And that's all driven by an
application that understands,
you know, what are the packages.
What are the locations?
What is traffic in the area--
you know, other disruptions
to a particular route?
And they use Google Maps to
do a lot of this in addition
to what they're
doing on the device
in their own application.
And if you're not
aware, there are
APIs that you can build other
capabilities into Google Maps.
So for example, if
you're a delivery driver,
maybe you have a
particular address.
But the loading dock happens
to be around the corner
on another physical address.
Or it might-- and it might
be a little bit difficult
to get to have to
pick the scenario.
You can build that
into the app so
that when the driver is
approaching his destination,
that driver is going
to the correct area,
navigating with
the right street--
makes it much more
efficient capability
to be able to deliver
those devices.
So it's been a huge
success in their deployment
and not only in terms
of helping the drivers,
but is there capturing
all the information
about what's happening.
What are the routes?
What are the failures in
the trucks and so forth?
There's a load of information
that produce analytics
that they can use to
dictate and determine
how they want to make
changes and what they
want to deploy in going forward
Marks & Spencer you may be
familiar with-- a big retailer
in the UK.
They worked with a
partner, Honeywell, to say,
you know what?
We want to build a
device in the future.
What the associates were
doing-- and they describe
to be five or six devices.
One is to check a price.
You know, one is to see
what's in the inventory.
One is to understand a
customer's order status,
you know, so on, and so forth.
They decided that they
would take one device.
And instead of having all
of these different devices
do things, they
would have one device
that has apps to run all
these different capabilities.
They spent a lot of
time actually working
with their associates
to understand
how they do their daily
job, what's problems,
what's headaches, and so forth.
And they rolled
this about a year
ago out to their customers.
And it's really interesting
when you listen to the video.
The woman that was actually
heading this up says this is--
I don't know how long she
had been at Marks & Spencer--
but this is probably the
most successful rollout
that they ever had.
You listen to some of
the associates talking
about how great it is to have
this device in their pocket
that makes their lives
that much easier.
What it results in at
the end of the day--
they have statistics that
they talk about in the video--
were improved customer
satisfaction, as well as
employee satisfaction
to a market degree.
And it all can be traced to when
they rolled this program out.
So there's hard
data in terms of how
this makes an actual
difference, not
just to your customers at the
end of day, but the employees,
as well.
Most of you are probably
familiar with Pitney Bowes--
a postage meter company.
Pitney Bowes a while back
decided that, you know what?
We need to change our
focus a little bit.
We need to incorporate some of
the new mobile capabilities.
We need to deliver things to our
customers in a different way.
We want to deliver
capabilities that they just
don't have today.
So what they did is
they worked with us.
They built a postage meter that
has an embedded 7-inch tablet
in it.
And what they deliver
to their users--
I'm not sure if you're
familiar with their background.
But all these are regulated.
So if you find a postage
meter in a customer account,
it's not-- nobody owns it.
That's all managed
by Pitney Bowes.
But what they do is
they deliver a web store
so that the customers can
buy certain services go well
beyond weighing a package
and making a delivery.
You know, part of
that is an application
that would do the calculation
for the customer to say,
listen.
Here's a package
going to x location.
It's y weight.
Use FedEx.
Or use UPS or if they choose
the most efficient or least
expensive way to go and
deliver that package.
There are other
capabilities that people
would use on a daily basis that
could be used on this device,
ranging from things like
inventory, time sheets,
and so forth.
So a device that you
think of as very simple--
you weigh a package.
You ship it-- can actually
be changed and used
to be able to deliver
capabilities to end users
that previously, you
wouldn't be able to deliver.
So MiCab is a company that's
based in the Philippines.
And they have a ride
sharing application.
They're taking-- I'm sure a
lot of people in this room
are familiar with Lyft or Uber
and what you get with your app
to be able to rate, understand
who's coming to get you,
what the reality is.
So imagine taking that
type of capability.
And what they did
was they applied that
to the taxicab industry.
So it's all taxi cabs as
opposed to Uber or Lyft.
But what they have is you
can think of three devices.
One is the driver's device that
sits in the front of the cab.
And it's generally a
smartphone type of form factor
that allows them to
get new customers,
understand what the route is
to the customer destination,
and so forth.
A device that's more tablet
sized is in the back seat.
And that's used to do everything
from display entertainment.
They have some ads capabilities.
They allow the customer
to pay on that device.
And of course, that's
all connected via an app
to the customer's device.
So all of this is tied together.
And when you think about this,
it sounds kind of simple.
And it's a taxicab app.
It allows you to understand that
who your driver is going to be.
And you're getting
in the right cab.
It's going to be well
maintained and so forth.
But think about it.
They're using these devices
to make their payment, right?
So they have to be
absolutely secure--
it's not just a matter
of making it available--
absolutely secure.
And it has to work, because
if it's not working,
they don't take payments.
And everything falls apart.
So this is kind of
an innovated way
of taking what we've
learned in other areas,
applying it to an existing
business to kind of transform
and make it more up to date in
terms of what customers expect.
And I want to play
a short clip here
in terms of what the
customer is looking for
and what they saw is
advantages about the platform
as was the partners
they were working with.
The key piece that they
wanted to talk about--
and again, this
is on the website.
So you can go and listen to
them tell it in their words.
But they've got thousands of
devices that are deployed,
you know.
And there's new cabs
coming online and so forth.
They have to do this remotely.
They have to be able
to do it easily.
They have to do in
an automated fashion.
They can't send someone out to
all these different locations
to be able to set it up
and deploy the devices.
All of this is managed by
the platform that's built
into Android Play Services.
And of course, as I
mentioned, security
is absolutely critical.
So they talk a little bit in
detail in the presentation
as to why they chose that
and what the impact was.
So Yumpingo is-- anybody
here from the UK, by the way?
No?
[LAUGHS]
OK.
Yumpingo is a company based in
London that goes to restaurants
and delivers a service,
whereby at the end of a meal,
they deliver a folder
along with your bill that
includes a device that
looks like a 5 and 1/2 inch
smartphone.
It's not a smartphone.
It's actually running one app.
And that app is to be able
to rate your experience--
to be able to rate, you know,
how the server was, cleanliness
of the restaurant, how the
food was, the different dishes,
and so forth.
Of course, it's
got all the detail,
because it's tied to the
order that was delivered.
And they've had unbelievable
response from customers
in terms of rating this.
Everybody seems to want to
go ahead and rate the app.
And what's important about
it is not only can they get--
it's kind of TripAdvisor type
scenario or Yelp and so forth--
ratings of that
particular restaurant
that they can publish.
They can advertise and so forth.
But they get really
critical information
about what's happening across
all of their enterprise.
It could be a small
restaurant chain
of three different locations.
But if one dish is
great at two of them
and really lousy at one or
service is the same way,
it's important to
know that, right?
It's important to get
that kind of information.
There's loads of
other more detail
that you can get out of
this type of application.
And when you think
about that and you're
thinking of various
applications that
matter to your
particular industry,
that type of analytical
approach and data gathering
would be critical in terms
of what you could actually
deliver.
So as far as use
cases, I'm going
to close with the last one.
This is actually my favorite.
And you know this is--
I had to have it rhyme, right?
So it's inspiration,
innovation, and celebration
the end of the day.
But the point I
want to make here
is if you're looking
at enterprise use cases
and you're looking at
what you want to do,
obviously there's a scenario
that you would think
can be improved or
that you can think
can be deliver capabilities
that's not previously done.
The important thing is to focus
on what is that inspiration.
What is that key use
case, because you
can innovate using the platform
to do some amazing things?
You're going to celebrate
at the end of the day.
But hopefully, the audio is
going to work on this next one,
because I want to lead
into it with an example
of that inspiration.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
Samantha and her friend--
[LAUGHS]
--I'll give the voiceover here--
traveled to Brazil a
while ago on vacation.
And the interesting
thing about Brazil,
if you know anything
about Brazil,
is nobody speaks English there.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
JACK WEIXEL: Nobody speaks
anything but Portuguese
as a matter of fact.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHS]
JACK WEIXEL: OK.
So a few people maybe, but what
actually ended up happening
is Samantha and her
friend walked in
to various restaurants and
would try to order and asked,
does anyone speak English?
And the answer, of
course, was always no.
And of course, not being
able to communicate
means that you can't
order anything.
So at the end of the day,
what ended up happening is
they walked out
of 11 restaurants
over the course of
the time and were not
able to order in any of them.
They return to the States.
And by this time, they
were really hungry.
[LAUGHTER]
So the first thing they
do is go to a restaurant
to be able to order something.
And the waiter
brings them a menu,
you know, takes their order,
understands what they want,
walks up to the cash register,
the point of sale device,
enters it in.
And at that point in time,
the inspiration strikes.
And so Samantha says to
her friend, you know,
wouldn't it be great if I
had a mobile tablet instead
of a paper tablet, right?
And I'd be able to understand
what I want and order it.
And by the way, maybe
I speak English.
Maybe I'm in Brazil.
But I would be able to order in
English so that I understand.
What ends up happening
in the kitchen
is they get the order in
whatever their local language
is.
And they'd be able
to prepare the food,
deliver it to the table.
And everything is good.
You know, everything
is wonderful.
So taking advantage of this
type of mobile application
can deliver a
scenario where you've
got less mistakes, faster
service, efficient staff,
and of course,
increase your revenue.
And from that
standpoint, that's--
Urban Translations was born.
[APPLAUSE]
[LAUGHS]
I've seen this once or twice.
So what actually happens-- this
was a scenario of a restaurant.
Urban Translations
has done a lot of work
not only in restaurants,
but hotels and resorts
to be able to deliver
capabilities such
that it's not just
ordering food, right?
Imagine when you
walk into a hotel.
And in your room, there's a
particular device that ends up
being your digital concierge.
And maybe you're ordering
food in a particular location.
Maybe you're asking
for certain services.
Maybe you want to find
out locations to go to.
To be able to communicate
in your own language
and to be able to
have that seamless
and allow us to interact, it
obviously helps the customer.
But it helps the staff as well.
And even if it's
not a scenario where
you have to do a translation,
the ability to walk in and have
a kiosk just in a
Marriott down the street,
for example so that--
what's that-- I don't even know.
I think it's the Enterprise
car commercial, right,
where the guy
says, well, I don't
have to talk to somebody
unless I want to.
And I don't want to.
I'm kind of that
guy, by the way.
[LAUGHS]
So the idea to be able to
just interact with the device
and get what you want is
kind of appealing to me.
So these are the
types of things that
even on something as simple
as you can't find someone
to take your order
or talk to you,
can lead to this inspiration
that allows you to focus
on new innovative scenarios.
So the key at the
end of the day--
innovate, right?
We've got a platform
that would allow
you to do it-- multiple form
factors, multiple sizes,
multiple price points.
All of these things exist
in the Android scenario.
These are devices
that you can use.
You can buy them off the shelf.
There are companies that will
work with you to private label
devices, regardless of what
that form factor happens to be.
We can help connect
you with those
so that you can build
these devices that
can be anything from a kiosk to
an order system and so forth.
At the end of the
day, yes, you're
getting productive employees.
You're really getting
happy customers.
But you're delivering
something that
makes your business
succeed and thrive.
And that's the type
of thing that we
want to deliver with Android,
we want to help you do.
So I'd encourage you
to take a look at this.
I want to work with you.
So if we can help
you do some of this,
I'd be more than
happy to engage myself
or some of the team members to
actually deliver some of this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]